[Applause]
that is a smart intro because we are
talking about one of the best uh
remembering one of the best flat we got
an unusual what to watch today we do uh
and we chose that music because we are
talking and paying tribute to one of the
giants of the fashion world andre
leontally the longtime creative director
for vogue magazine has died at age 73.
tally who was six feet six was literally
a towering presence at vogue and blazed
the trail for black people in the
fashion industry tally lifted himself
from humble beginnings in north carolina
and found the spotlight in new york city
[Applause]
a fashion editor with a vast knowledge
of its history who had a colorful sense
of style himself andre leontale used his
talents to carve a unique position in an
industry not known for being especially
welcoming to african americans culture
journalist travell anderson i think it's
important for us to recognize that he
did face a lot of racism in his time
and his way of navigating that was just
by biting the bullet and pushing through
because he saw something for himself on
the other side
born the grandchild of a sharecropper to
become one of the most powerful black
people in fashion history tally used his
southern perspective formal education
and drive to succeed catching the eye of
new york's fashion elite including vogue
magazine editor-in-chief anna wintour
she made him the magazine's first black
creative director in 1988. tally spoke
to gail king in may of 2020. i felt i
had no pressure i felt it was important
to simply represent the outstanding
excellence for the firms that i worked
for for women's wear daily and vogue i
sat on the front row they didn't have me
there because of the way i looked they
had me there because of my knowledge and
my smartness but while tally says he's
grateful for winter he says the two did
have a falling out professionally and
personally when he says she
unceremoniously uninvited him from
hosting at the star-studded met gala in
favor of a younger so-called social
media influencer where would you say
your relationship stands today because
it does seem a tad messy
i think my relationship is in an ice
iceberg with her
i hope that it will not be that forever
i think it's in an iceberg with an ice
floe on instagram tuesday fashion icon
diane von furstenberg paid tribute to
tally saying no one saw the world in a
more elegant and glamorous way than you
did no one was more soulful and grander
than you were the world will be less
joyful now he was a titan he opened up
so many doors put so many cracks in
ceilings that he himself could not break
it's a complicated legacy but it's a
beautiful one nonetheless
so
how does a relationship stand with vogue
well i haven't i've been checking their
twitter accounts i haven't seen a tweet
the last tweet that i see has something
to do with um uh cynthia nixon uh so
they haven't commented at least on
social media but i i think what i'm sure
they will say something i think she had
long history with them right and then
this happened overnight and uh they
don't need to
us like who knows what they're thinking
we don't know right we don't know um but
what i do know is that andre leontally
for many many many many years was the
only one and he talked about in his book
how difficult that was but how he
carried on he said i would put on my
armor and go out there and if you're a
person of color if you're a woman if
you're lgbtq you kind of know what that
means that means that you rule zero
right you take those arrows but if
you're the only one
it's a much different type of armor that
you wear and he wanted to open the door
for others i can remember being at
events and andre leontaly would really
breeze into the room he had this long
fur coat that was like eight feet long
and he carried it like a bear walking in
yeah when he walked in the room you knew
he was there and he would watch he used
to watch us a lot and he would send he
would send me notes and say i i like
what you're wearing today and other
times he would say not sure about that
but he was he would always do it in a
kind way i really respected him really
admired him and really cared about him
he talked about his struggle with his
weight he talked about not being
accepted so it's one of those things i
said at the top of the newscast that you
go to bed
yeah that was at rihanna's black ball
actually a few years ago
but you know you you go to bed in the
news business and you wake up and the
world is totally changing when i first
saw the dates i thought did andre leon
tally pass you can't believe what you're
reading right and they haven't said the
cause of death yet they have not
although he had some health
complications in his uh last couple of
months last couple of years i i also
think what he said and to you gail about
hopefully one day that relationship
would flower again with
banana winter um the only thing that
money can't buy is time and that's what
that means when you say you woke up this
morning and you saw the new year
i saw him once walking down the street
he was a towering figure he was six six
yes life and in fashion